the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
one of the ways to think about the
American Musical generally is to
recognize that it's a distinctive maybe
even a unique American form and with the
American and with the Western movie the
two most distinctive contributions that
Hollywood has made to the art of
moviemaking listen to this entry on
musicals the very beginning of the entry
on musicals from the Oxford Companion to
film the history of the screen musical
is essentially that of the American
Musical the outstanding examples of the
genre have been made in Hollywood and
only the American industry has
consistently produced musicals
throughout the sound era the book was
written just in the book was published
in the early 70s just as movies
Hollywood movies were undergoing the
transformation I've alluded to indeed
with the Western the musical could be
claimed as Hollywood's outstanding
contribution to the history of cinema so
that's a good context for thinking both
about the westerns we'll be talking
about in the next two weeks and about
the musicals we're talking we're
thinking about this week perhaps before
we go any further it would be useful for
me to give a very quick talk about the
problem of definition because there is
music in almost all films how do we how
do we distinguish a musical a true
musical from a film that contains music
and the simplest answer is also the most
obvious one we would embrace a
definition I think that would say that a
film in which song and dance are so
essential that to remove them would
leave virtually nothing means you're
watching a musical and that would
distinguish it then from many many films
in which musical elements may be present
even musical performances may be present
but they are not at the very essence of
what the film is and the film is not in
time the film is not entirely dependent
upon those elements right so a simple
straightforward definition one way we
can measure the significance the
centrality of the musical - and also of
the Western because the
numbers are somewhat similar for the
Western the centrality of the musical to
the studio system is to look at the
numbers and between 1927 and 1947 or
just over 900 films
musical films were made that's in a star
well for approximately 48 films a year
that's roughly 10% of the total
production of movies during that period
were musicals and one of the things that
shows of course is how steady the
audience for musicals were we're how
stable the system became relatively
quickly allowing for the elaboration and
and repetition the fuller exploration of
this particular genre of movie and you
can see you can recognize the decline
too there are people who would argue
that the musical in its exuberance and
the American musical especially in its
exuberance and optimism represented as
some essentially a pre-war value and and
there are people who say well after the
war the musical began a decline there
are other explanations for why the
musical began its decline and the
primary one is the one I've already
implied the studio system was breaking
down and the captive audience of
millions and millions of people who went
to the movies every week was
disappearing but in the period between
1949 and 1958 a much briefer period only
23 films a year were made they were
still a significant proportion of the
Hollywood output but you can understand
you could see the tremendous decline and
then in the period between 59 and 1980
only seven films that could be named
musicals a year the genre is virtually
not exactly extinct but it's now a
specialty item and musicals continue to
be made but they're but they are hardly
part of the regular fare of movie of
moviegoers so we can think of the
musical as one of the distinctive
expressions of the Hollywood studio era
and and in its in their optimism and in
their in maybe in even in their relative
reluctance to engage directly with
political and social questions they
express a certain value or or a certain
perspective that particularly
illuminates the remarkable
entertainment industry that Hollywood
became I want to just say a very few
words about the dominant themes in these
films they're what you might expect from
this combination of music and comedy one
recurring topic is the theme of show
business right many films have as that
many musical films have as their plot
there's a kind of sub-genre of musical
films devoted to the question of putting
on a show right and the drama of the of
this subcategory of musicals is you
begin at the beginning with the the cast
being assembled and you watch the
difficulties the internal and public
difficulties that the show has getting
on the boards right and one very common
that this is derived in some sense from
a from forms of from forms of musical
performance that existed on Broadway
before they migrated to Hollywood before
they before they were adopted and
adapted by Hollywood so and as and
what's embedded in this show business
theme for example are larger themes and
one of them is the theme of community in
other words you'll see and you'll see a
very concrete and dramatic articulation
or dramatization of these principles in
singing in the rain this evening all of
the film all of the themes I'm talking
about now you-you-you will find I think
expressed dramatized with great
authority and and wit in in singin in
the rain so the idea is that the putting
on of a show means that you have a
community of people who have to get
along together and what what what is
discovered in the tensions and problems
that begin to develop there are things
that have to do if we jump down in my
categories to the next one not too high
culture popular but to the next one to
class or position you can see that in
some sense the theme of community leads
also then at least implicitly into a
into an interest in the relative the
questions of hierarchy as against
questions of talent right and and what's
in other words you know I'm the
important singer but might but but but
my understudy has the better voice
what's the tension there what's going to
happen there and you'll see how this
theme what with wonderful comic energy
plays itself out in singin in the rain
but what I want you to recognize as
embedded in that theme is what we not
only in what I'm calling the theme of
community or the theme of class right
social class or or social hierarchy or
social position and the tension between
individual talent and social position
which is repeatedly expresses itself at
least implicitly in these music what
does this say that one that the musicals
do have at some level a kind of implicit
political subject matter that they that
they heart that that they're often about
democracy or about how to get along and
in fact during the recent crisis in most
recent crisis of partisan disagreement
in Congress I was thinking gee if I
could send them a couple of musicals and
if they pay attention to them maybe they
could get along too probably too hopeful
an idea but there is a political
dimension to the to the to the drama
even to the confined drama of putting on
a show that some very good musicals
bring to the surface another central
theme is the one I skipped over the
conflict often attention or a conflict
between high and popular culture with
Hollywood and the musical film almost
always standing on the side of the
popular as against the more abundant and
pretentiously a sclerotic old-fashioned
older forms and they often create a kind
of cartoon of the older forms in order
to celebrate their own energy but this
tension is a recurring one in musicals
and you'll see you'll see versions of
these themes in both the musicals that
are on our roster for this evening
finally implicit in what I've been
saying is the is the theme of convention
and restraint versus spontaneity energy
what we think of as the natural and I'll
say more about this tonight when we talk
about the dance sequences in singin in
the rain but at the moment just let me
emphasize the extent to which this
principle of a kind of conflict between
what is handed down what is conventional
what is expected and what is dictated by
your spontaneous needs desires a sense
of joy is a is a constant source of
tension and and and energy in in many
musicals and is one of the central
organizing principles of singing in the
rain and we'll come back to that tonight
when we when I talk more fully about
that film well what I'd like to do with
the time I have left is try to
illustrate in a certain way two
different things and they're partly in
conflict but they are the kinds of and
and therefore in some sense I'm
simplifying but it's but it's an
intellectually justifiable
simplification what I want to do
simultaneously is give you a kind of
brief sense of the history of the
musical but also a sense of the
different flavors within little broad
category of the musical that might be
possible this is obviously an impossible
task in 30 minutes or so but we're going
to accomplish it anyway in a very
reduced and and crystallized way I think
as you might imagine the central impetus
for the musical occurred technologically
with the advent of sound right as soon
as sound became possible people were
thinking ah we can sing in the movies
music is going to be important in the
movies and of course that was in fact
the case the very first sound film the
jazz singer was about singing it had ten
interpolated songs in it and only two
lines of dialogue in it Al Jolson the
famous blackface performer played a
performer in blackface a Jew actually a
white man who played a black and most
famously in on stage in this particular
film he plays religious families the son
of a religious family of a Jewish family
who who wants to sing jazz not to be a
cantor in the synagogue and his father's
very angry at him because he thinks he's
betraying and can you see embedded there
is the theme of in certain sense high
religious culture versus popular culture
in the very first film that might affect
that interpolated music that theme is
already present and the the in in 1928
Jolson again appeared in a sound in us
you know you know in a film called the
singing fool that made a great success
and and what then followed in 1929 were
a whole series of musical films of films
that incorporated music in
in 1929 a film called the Broadway
melody of 1929
and it contained a backstage story like
the one I've already described about two
sisters from vaudeville who trying to
reach Broadway and star on Broadway and
and therefore the putting on of a show
is one of the implicit subjects but this
form of early musical was derived from
Broadway in a very direct way and it
often did not have a coherent plot it
was often in it often involved a series
of song singing and dancing numbers
interspersed with comic dialogue of some
kind are literally a revue not a play
right and then some versions of the
revue began to have more systematic
plots talking linking this animated I
think generated by this theme of putting
honor of putting on a play and the
Broadway melody of 1929 was an
astonishing success it was partly
because it was the most fully successful
most fully musicalized film up to that
time and it it it was so popular it was
incidentally the songs written for it
were written by herb nacio Brown and
Arthur freed the two people who are at
the center of singin in the rain now CEO
Browns songs are in singin in the rain
and Arthur freed of course is the great
executive producer responsible for more
of the great musicals in the Hollywood
era than any other figure so they begin
even early that early at the very
earliest stages of the mediums history
and so then the Broadway melody became
was so popular and so successful that in
1930 70 new musicals were produced
mostly in imitation and and the film won
an Oscar for for best film so it's it
immediately established musical films
films with music song and singing and
dancing in them as a central category
most early musicals were reviews of this
sort very early ones they combined they
used Broadway Hollywood vaudeville and
radio stars incorporated them in Rat
lavash musical numbers interspersed with
sketches and again they were not
necessarily coherent
and some of them most of them didn't
even attempt to present a coherent plot
this kind of film more coherently
plotted remained a subcategory of
musicals all the way through the musical
the history of musicals and that's why
that's why I want to qualify the idea
that I'm giving you a history I am
giving you a kind of history but it's a
complicated history because the forms
I'm talking about don't completely
disappear and get supplanted by the more
advanced forms they live together
simultaneously and the question of
whether one is a more advanced form than
another might be debatable although I
think there are distinctions as you'll
see that do suggest that there's a kind
of progression and increasing
understanding of what it would mean to
make a musical film that was truly
coherent that wasn't simply presenting
us with the joy of song and dance in a
in a way unconnected to story or
character but but it remained a
subcategory that this this revue
remained a subcategory of musical films
all the way through the history and of
the of the form and in 1946 one of the
most remarkable versions of this was
made it was called Ziegfeld Follies and
again it was based on honor it was a
film about a nostalgic film about a
Broadway phenomenon but it was a fully
integrated film of a form that was
popular in the knighted States but even
much more popular in Europe the staged
operetta it was a it was like it wasn't
a full opera it was often a kind of
smaller comic drama that involves
singing and dancing when they were
called operettas because they were
understood to be smaller versions of
opera more amusing less demanding
versions of opera supposed less
pretentious and and tragic versions of
opera and and there were a number of
European directors who when they
emigrated to the United States brought
their distinctive feel to the making of
early musicals and some of the most
powerful artistically powerful early
musicals fell into the category not of
the review but of the operetta and I
want to show you one version of such a
of such a film now
one of my favorite passages from from
the great director Rouben Mamoulian in
1932 a passage from the seat a scene
from love me tonight made in 1932 it's a
long sequence I may have to skip some of
it but let me set it up for you in this
film maurice chevalier who's whose
English is so terrible that you'll have
trouble understanding him his French
accent is so deep at this point he
became much better at English because as
some of you I hope realize he became a
great star in the english-speaking world
as well as in France but in this in this
film he said this is I'm one of his
earliest films if not his first English
film and and he plays even though he's
very well dressed here he plays a
working man a middle class a tailor he
plays a tailor and he owns a tailor shop
in Paris and in this opening scene one
of the men that he one of the
aristocrats whose clothing he he makes
comes in to be fitted out for his
wedding outfit and maurice chevalier
does so the plot of the film depends
upon the fact that maurice chevalier
this middle-class tailor who's trying to
make a living in paris in his shop is
brought into the ambit of an
aristocratic family of a royal family
and a bit because there is an aristocrat
who for whom maurice chevalier has made
a great many suits who owes him money
and maurice chases him to his castle in
the country trying to find - trying to
recover his money and romantic
entanglements and sue and the and and
the larger part of the film actually
involves a romance across social class
between this Parisian tailor and a
princess played by Jeanette MacDonald
one of the great musical stars of the
studio of the studio era so here is the
scene from very early in lovely tonight
all right
this is a very quick observation I can't
interrupt too often because I have a lot
of clips to show you when they're more
important than my commentary but let me
remind you that even if it's very early
a stage in the history of the musical
look at how visually sophisticated
Mamoulian is because you're what and pay
attention as the film as the sequence
goes on but look at how he's working
with the mirrors here and how it's
doubling what it does to your sense of
perspective and your sense of the
environment of the shop this is a
visually sophisticated very thoughtful
artistically manipulated camera and it's
memorials work so very early in the
history of the music were already
getting visually subtle effects
that's Jeanette MacDonald okay we have
two lights awesome thank you alright I
hope you enjoyed that lovely sequence
it's called that that device is called a
pass-along a song I've written it on the
board and you can and but and I won't
say more about how witty and wonderful
the film is except to suggest that apart
from its wonderfully amusing and witty
qualities I hope you implicitly
recognized why I took the time to
describe the plot to you because what
does the music do what does this song do
in this early part of the film it
predicts the plot it predicts the story
it carries the story into the
countryside to the very castle where the
plot will take Maurice from Paris later
in the story and not only that what is
dramatized by the way in which this song
moves from tailor to aristocratic
well-dressed man to composer artist to
cabdriver to soldier to gypsy to
Princess Jeanette and and also that it
covers physical territory as well as CRO
but it crosses social barriers it
crosses it it crosses it crosses
particular social classes it crosses
differences of gender it crosses ethnic
difficult what does it say about music
music creates community music is
democratic music can overcome barriers
which is going to be ultimately the
message of the film itself so it's an
immensely subtle crystallized moment in
the film and it has all kinds of
powerful thematic implications for later
in the film apart from the fact that
it's a wonderfully rich introduction to
the primary character and to the joys of
music reality is however that until the
advent in in something like nineteen
thirty 33 of work by Busby Berkeley the
great choreographer and director working
at this stage primarily for the Warner
Brothers Studio did we begin to see
forms of the movie forms of film forms
cinema that that were uniquely adapted
to the nature of music of music itself
that is to say Busby Berkeley became a
legend in Hollywood for the immense
extravagance and and elaborateness of
his dance numbers and of his production
numbers they were an elaboration of
something that was popular on in the
Broadway theatre before the the advent
of movies but what Berkeley did was take
this tendency of the broadway theater
and cinema ties it in a certain way and
we could get it we can get some sense of
what berkeley was like what Berkeley's
work is like by talking about the way in
which he created a new attitude toward
film spaces
he loved to create receding arches and
doorways and even waterfalls and to
destroy what we might call theatrical
space by exploring the camera's powers
coupled with the power of editing and
the power of editing now linked to
rhythms of music so he created
essentially a choreography for the
camera no seated audience could have had
the views and experiences that the Busby
Berkeley production numbers began to
provide and there's a moment in singing
in the rain tonight that explicitly
recalls this tradition of the musical
there's a moment in which a character in
the film has a megaphone and the front
of the megaphone dissolves into a circle
of costumed dancers in a sequence called
beautiful girls that's the name of the
number and that whole number is an
homage to this Busby Berkeley tradition
well they were there were certain
disadvantages to the Berkeley strategy
one of them was that especially in in
the extremity with which he began to
pursue his expressive aims he began to
sort of dematerialize his women he began
to objectify them and many of his films
many of his production numbers literally
objectified parts of a woman's body
especially breasts and bottom and legs
and and the oume there's almost in a
certain sense a kind of dehumanizing
impulse in which the humor in which the
human figures especially when he used
you
often would use cameras that would rise
very hard look he invented a shot called
the Berkeley top shot often cut a hole
in the ceiling of the places in which
they were filming so he could move up
higher and who had film from so far
above that the individual lineaments of
bodies would disappear and only the
patterns that they made appeared what he
anticipated was MTV and forms of
expressive filmmaking that severs a
musical experience or a via an
audio-visual experience animated by
music driven by music from subject from
plot from story in other words there's
something in some one sense very
visionary about what Busby Berkeley was
doing but of course he was doing this
often in the middle always in the middle
of films that had stories and characters
and one of the issues in his films were
the production numbers were far more
lavish interesting and really and and
energy aesthetically energized than the
stories that carried them and it was
really in a certain sense the stories
were really the the platform to generate
these kinds of these so there were these
kinds of performance so the films were
not as aesthetically coherent as one
would like but they were full of these
astonishingly expressive musical numbers
of audio-visual experiences and I'll
sure let me just show you one that that
will give you a sense of his
extravagance even even of his of his of
his more than except these extremism in
a certain in a certain sense although
that's part of the pleasure we take it
how far he can go there's something
deeply camp deeply campy about Busby
Berkeley's choreography and he reveled
he reveled in these kinds of gestures
but here is one of the most famous of
the although not by far the most extreme
or ridiculous of these kinds of gestures
from a film Berkeley made in 1933 called
42nd Street
see how we started it clear to the
Spence dick power than the greatest
performers of the studio era of music
music
the Berkeley tough shot
see how he's moved to a kind of
abstraction here
you think you might do something almost
grotesque about suppose luckily images
on the other end can you also see how in
a system that is censored in which women
are not allowed to be seen on on a bed
with a without one foot at least on the
ground on the floor in which there is a
kind of sexual energy and a kind of
testing of boundaries running through
this kind of this kind of display as
well
we're running out of time and I have
another even more magnificent sequence
to show you to finish out this attempt
to give you at least a quick flavor of
the varieties of experience available in
the musical before we look at a fully
integrated musical this evening with
singing in the rain and let me say very
quickly then to jump to the bottom the
final aspect of this is what Arthur
freed and his cohorts articulated as the
idea of a musical that would integrate
sufficiently music and dance with
character and story in a way that would
be coherent and the musicals main under
Arthur Fried's Direction often called
the freed unit at MGM tried to satisfy
this criterion they were in many ways
more coherent in terms of the relation
between the singing and the dancing and
the story than these earlier forms were
although they were often less
imaginatively expressive in some K in in
some cases although this is not true I
think of singing in the rain well but
there's a but there is a another stage
to mention in this development or
revolution and it's one of the most
important in the history of the
Hollywood musical and has to do with the
partnership between Fred Astaire and
Ginger Rogers mostly at the RKO studios
they made nine films together between
1933 and 1939 at RKO and they introduced
another element into the musical film
that is then I think incorporated in
certain degrees in a certain degree in
the so-called integrated musical of MGM
so my last example this afternoon comes
from the great astaire-rogers musical
top hat and let me set the stage for you
get ready to show it Chris because we're
running out of time the situation is
this and it dramatizes even more fully
the idea that there are potentially
sexual tension sexual themes embedded in
the experience of watching a
song-and-dance musical the what the
astaire-rogers musicals brought to the
table that had not been there before was
a what what in some sense a kind of
psychological element you know even
though the in the astaire-rogers films
the singing and dancing was still in
some sense much more central to the film
than the rest of the story and the
stories were often thin what they did
introduced was an individual right in
the Busby Berkeley numbers you can see
the women are all the characters in fact
are are hard to differentiate from this
from the from the backdrop or from the
curtains they are they are objectified
in a certain way they become especially
when he gets going they become parts of
an abstract pattern in the in the
astaire-rogers films Astaire and Rogers
characters are deeply sharply
individuated and certain kinds of
psychological themes begin to enter in
in this clip you're going to see now a
fairly characteristic one and probably
the single most famous dance number in
the student of the history of the studio
era a dance number called based on the
song cheek-to-cheek danced by Astaire
and Rogers in the in this sequence that
we are in a setting that's worth
mentioning to you we're on board a
cruise ship
we'll see Americans are there right it's
wealthy people aristocrats the the the
the Astaire and Rogers characters have
met earlier and they haven't really hit
it off right and the Rogers character
the woman thinks that Fred Astaire is a
is an immoral man that he pretty bit
that he that he commits infidelities
against his wife and she's under the
mistaken impression that the woman he's
with is his wife so what happens in the
sequence essentially is that in front of
what she believes to be his wife he asks
her to dance he asked Rogers to dance
with her and then to her surprise
Astaire's apparent wife says oh go ahead
I'd love to see you two together and she
says well and and and so what was when
the film went when the dance
jeans you can she's sort of resistant
right she's thinking this is the sky she
goes along with it but she but she feels
there's something wrong about it and
then as the dance goes on you can see
her resistance begin to break down and
you can see her the dance becoming more
and more mutual and you can see her
enthusiasm for the dance increase and
think about what the dance first of all
how profound and bring it the day this
dance is as a as an embodiment of
mutuality and collaboration because one
of the reasons Rogers was so remarkable
was that she was that she was capable of
dancing at the same complex astonishing
level as Fred Astaire himself and
there's a it's an image of mutuality and
of collaborative artistry that's very
remarkable but it's also a metaphor for
other kinds of mutual interactions that
are physical and I hope you will pay
attention to that subtext as you're
watching this remarkable sequence the
fact that Rogers begins in an act
hastily really resistant and yield
slowly is a key to the energy we see
here okay
Ginger Rogers
now remember ginger is mistaken about
this friends not really married to her
and of course that's a typical holiday
trick because we're able to enjoy the
free song of infidelity and of the idea
of estranged from your wife but it isn't
really true
you see how the misunderstanding adds
tremendous sexual energy to equate to
the zoo
together
I'm gonna do the terrible damage just
keep watching as I'm talking and imagine
you're hearing the song right
but because we're running out of time I
don't want to lose our energy I want to
keep you over so this stance continues
that as you'll see it's quite a long
sequence and me singing to her and he's
really really not a very good singer is
he doesn't seem to matter but one of the
things you should watch is the way they
move out of a crowded space into a more
private space and what and the intimacy
of there and now the dance partly stops
for a moment then it resumes and then
they move they they they they move as
you're seeing this in the sequence they
may move into a space that's completely
private and her and you if you watch her
expression you can also see that she's
beginning to heal but she's beginning to
become enthusiastic okay put that sound
back on
and I seem to find when we're together
dancing
my final comment we're coming to near
near the end of the sequence although it
will extend what you hear the music too
but watch especially the way the
intensity of this picks up and then we
suspended and then and then subsides ask
yourself what rhythms are being
implicitly dramatized here and then why
at the very end it's time for a
cigarette okay
you
you